oh hello welcome to this video playing
Grand Master Maxine blue key that's a
cool opponent he's a really strong
player I've got a plus one score though
against him so interesting to see what
happens here so early 84 here against my
pseudo banker 10 but whatever you make
over to call it it's going c4 here
interesting how can I do something be no
knees down I don't think he's on a show
right now I just play some fun he has a
show of course take it to the max on
them on the ICC and I've played him on
that show actually funny games we had ok
I'm going to play against this Bishop
him yeah I wonder about a quick f5
probably not but I wanted to get Jesus
fear kiddo in and I wasn't sure that I
manage if I don't play Knight age 5
check I wants to go Knights afford ok
it's not not a big deal i think i can
still cancel be towards hanging so i
don't think he can take these six so
what's going on nitey 50
[Music]
that's I would absolutely love to play
f5 and disposition would he takes it and
he has this yes there's some this fork
what else training this bishop would
also be good I can check him I unknown
then Cree GF 6
should d7 doesn't do much I can do this
and Bishop a six maybe I wonder if he
has three four actually I somehow did
not have this on the radar okay I'll go
back there to be ready to retreat to f6
in case of this yeah here we go one
thing is good is night as miles away
from the sea foursquare oh wow
I will I will have some compensation
hear that that is I think pretty clear
but how much how much it is it's not so
clear I Scott Bishop c6 that's not
that's not there's no reason to go into
panic mode IAM i would always have
compensation here on the dark squares
okay both moves make sense in this year
for Queen to c5
this game position is quite quite unsafe
is Queen d5 that's what he has rook
takes immense 25 business ok I can take
g4 but it wasn't planned you know it was
not planned 94 25 is what I overlooked
ok take this one
very messy position okay going for some
kind of double attack I guess I put my
bishops are hanging let's let's not
let's not again no panic mode I've got
less time it doesn't mean all that much
let's do it this level is quincy fire so
that that he cannot play and i'm just
getting this exam
d 7 25 25 check check that's no good so
let's check to do this time morning
check how to do this here's a chick so
probably step here Luke g8 quite
resigned yep got it yeah somehow I don't
know I'm feeling quite well against and
this is probably it was so messy you
probably we both were winning at some
point and that's very likely um yeah
okay he sees making all those moves on
going to and now he stopped examining
attack him so let's let's see him
extremely messy opening but ok he plays
the London in ambitious way so after b5
he tried something interesting he was a
four okay when to b4 c4 c6 that looks
quite logical and here okay night h5 in
me later let make some sense yeah the
bishop doesn't have great squares but ok
this should be somewhat playable at
least she's 692 check maybe both
basically went and we were inventing
things as they came along g for now ok
this assistant to
much yeah this looks dangerous yeah I
cannot really cover this night see form
I mean a position like that is still
quite messy in a blitz game but that is
good for watching okay so probably then
I am needed to improve earlier I mean
here it's not that bad yeah I took took
a long time here and I was a bit scared
about g4 he did it anyway and this must
be okay here really i don't i don't
believe in this so much we should be six
right that's not a move i saw it
interesting yeah yeah I get enormous
compensation if I get this pawn my
compensation is excellent him on the
dark squares this weekend disposition so
much yeah II for was just yeah the most
active move that I that I saw it seems
that there is an advantage for whitey
with g5 but all this is extremely
difficult to do and Here I am actually
clearly better look at seven right okay
that's not very human yeah 81 so here we
have an equal ish position if white
plays correctly at d7 yeah I was
actually thinking check if he goes to in
the corner he has this counter threat
the king of one was was giving it away
he I wasn't sure actually because 25 is
on this is chang of course Bishop p.m.
and something like this Jim equal very
likely actually am the pawn or disable
prevents me from activating my pieces
and he cannot convert the porn because
his King is so big so
the draw is very very probable that
somehow you played King as one change
was giving it giving it away yeah nice
window thanks for watching